days after a man is charged with
assaulting a ccsd bus driver he's now
speaking out saying there's more to the
story that parent telling 8 news now he
was only defending himself madison
kimbrough on this story joining us in
studio after speaking with him madison
46 year old otis tanner is out on bail
after he got into a verbal and physical
altercation with a ccsd bus driver that
was last week oda stating that he was
defending students for an incident that
had happened a day prior but when he
confronted the bus driver things got out
of control
he puts his hands in his face and he
grabs me again at that time i push him
off of me and i tell him quit touching
me parent otis tanner recalling the
moments that led up to the tense
altercation on a bus full of students
thursday tanner who was arrested on
several charges claims he was just
defending himself against the bus driver
tanner stating that the day before his
daughter and a couple of other students
were kicked off the same bus by that
same bus driver for reasons unknown at
this time tanner alerted ccsd and says
the principal of valley high school
where his daughter goes to school said
they would address the issue however
tanner wanted to talk to the bus driver
himself one on one i was standing on the
steps when i was talking to him and i
and i told him and i said hey you know
this and that at this time he gets out
of his he gets up takes off his seatbelt
gets out of his seat
and he comes at me and says get the elf
off the bus and he grabs me and tries to
throw me
down the stairs at this point none of
this is on camera but tanner says after
the bus driver dispatched campus police
that's when things escalated he kept
antagonizing provoking me do something
do something which you heard in the
video
while we were off the bus he retreated
back to the bus and grabbed the weapon
they called a tire iron and proceeded to
come back after telling me he was going
to bust my head
and he tried that he come after me then
the situation ended when another parent
stepped in says otis but looking back he
says although he doesn't feel like he
was in the wrong he now would have
handled the situation differently in
front of the kids
and according to otis there was a new
bus driver in his neighborhood picking
up students today no word on the other
bus driver's condition otis is due back
in court tomorrow morning back to you
brian madison thank you that case one of
two involving ccsd bus drivers in recent
weeks it comes after the school district
invested millions to add cameras inside
each and every school bus but drivers
say they still have concerns because
those cameras they don't stop the
attacks some suggest an aid be added on
board so the driver can focus on the
road